If the Bible says that by his stripes, we are healed. Why do we still have cancer?
Because they're talking about a passage in the book of Isaiah that it says by his stripes,
we are healed. And that has been interpreted by some Christian denominations
incorrectly that, well, Jesus died for our diseases and that he's going to heal all our diseases
and that Jesus healed everybody. Well, that's not correct interpretation of that. It doesn't
say that. So it says by his stripes, we are healed, but does that mean that we're healed of our
diseases or that by his stripes, by his suffering and death and resurrection.
Here we're celebrating Easter this week. By his suffering, his death on the prophet is
resurrection. We now have access to the Father. So we have access to our heavenly Father through
the new covenant because of what Jesus did. It doesn't mean that we are going to be healed of our
all our diseases. Does Jesus, does God still heal today? Of course he does. Let's be honest,
I am only breathing and speaking to you right now because of God's sustaining grace that gives me
the ability to be alive right now. So he has in the process of keeping me alive right now for me to
even be functioning without his sustaining grace on my life, I would already be dead. So he is doing
that as he promised to heal all my diseases and to cure all my problems and to give me financial
blessing and to buy me a Mercedes, that's just nonsense. And that is totally wrong interpretation
of scripture, usually manipulation in order to manipulate the people to for some pastor to make a
fortune off of something. And it's very incorrect and ungodly. And that's not correct interpretation
of scripture. Does God still heal today? Yes, he does. Did he heal at the, did Jesus heal when he came
here and he was functioning living as a man on earth? Of course he did. We can see that all the way
through the gospels. Did the apostles heal? Were they given ability to heal people? Yes, we can see
that in the book of the accident apostles. Does Jesus heal that way today? Well, yes, he does.
And you can see testimonials of people that were healed miraculously. You know, their alcoholism,
their sex addiction, their cancer, their diseases. But does God do that in that way all the time?
Of course he doesn't. And we're all going to die. You know, all the apostles died. All our ancestors
died. That what the healing that we receive through Christ that is promised if we surrender our
life to him. And he is the Lord of our life. Through, um, through us surrendering to him is that
we're healed for the kingdom of heaven today in order to be a blessing to be a witness to have that
relationship with him. And for that future grace of being able to be in heaven and live forever
and ever and ever with him. If that's a good enough for us, then we're something, you know, selfish
and self-centered going on in our mind. I don't need to be healed of my cancer. For God to prove
who he is for me. If I need anything from God to prove who he is, then, you know, I already know I
don't have a right relationship with him. My relationship with him is surrender. That that and I allow
circumstances in my life, cancer and hardship and financial stress and family stress and relationship
stress, which we all have. That's an all driver's deeper to indeed to have that deeper relationship
with him. Um, that's the whole purpose of life. Our purpose in life is not to have, you know, health
and wealth and prosperity and everything going perfect. Our purpose of life is to have that deep
relationship with him so we could go to him when we have troubles, when we have struggles, when we have
pain, so that we allow our struggles to drive us deeper in that relationship with him so that we're
more and more depended upon him on a daily basis. That's what my purpose in life is, is to become more
depended upon him today than I was yesterday. And we need to allow our struggles, our ill health, our
ill finances, our ill relationships to to do that work in us. And that's what living in the kingdom
is. And salvation is not just for some future time to go to heaven. Salvation is for us to be in the
kingdom now, depended upon God having a right relationship with our heavenly Father because
of Jesus Christ and through and only through Jesus Christ, we could have that relationship with him
that we could communicate to him and pour out our struggles to him and he could comfort us and we
can climb up on his lap and we can be comforted by him and we could hear him say words to us that
that he loves us and he cares for us. And that's what we need. That's what my purpose is, is to have
that deeper relationship today than what I had yesterday. And I feel like that every day and I just
come back to it every day and I'm reminded through my struggles to come back to it.